dad is there something you want yes
there is to connect with this girl right
here now come on pretend I'm not your
dad we're just a couple of friends
kicking it in a juice bar
what's a juice bar okay I'm all shop
whatever dad no who's dad who's dad I'm
I'm Marcus from biology hey Haley how's
it going with you and Dylan does he
tried anything inappropriate with you
girl a malt shop sipping an egg cream
like Phil Dunphy the dad on the TV show
Modern Family many parents try to be
their child's best friend but clinical
psychologist dr. Wendi mogul argues that
should not be the goal John in her new
book in her new book sorry it was
writing lessons about my daughter down
voice lessons for parents what to say
how to say it and when to listen she
says that using certain communication
techniques can help kids be successful
your pitch how fast you talk your tone
of voice and body language all play an
important role the book is published by
Scribner an imprint of Simon & Schuster
a division of CBS dr. windy mogul good
morning
were you taking notes and extra
questions I don't even know where to
begin anywhere anywhere well it's so
what interests me is it's there's the
problem of being their friend and then
with teenagers it's sometimes just
hoping that you're not their enemy yeah
and understanding what they're going
through so let's start with young girls
what are we misunderstanding when our
daughter comes down for breakfast in the
morning about what her life is like so
our four-year-old daughters are as
articulate as any head of state on the
planet and we mistake their verbal
sophistication for emotional maturity so
they're still full they don't have much
life experience but they have tremendous
vocabularies and a great passion for
arguing into you into any perspective
they wish they're like little tiny
attorneys and the four-year-old boys can
barely talk yet but what do you said
about teenage girls I think
really interesting because you said that
you know that's part of the that's part
of the hardest stage of life for mothers
and their teenage daughters that to me
was fascinating because what the teenage
daughters do is they download all of
their distress ever and now everybody's
so connected by technology so they can
just text mom distress all day long and
then the mothers are in tremendous
anguish about the daughter's problems
and they predict they mistake the
snapshot of their daughter for the epic
movie of her life and so mother is
suffering the daughter's fine she just
handed it all over to mom and off she
goes you say don't go ahead my daughter
is such a lawyer she almost wears a
powdered wig so you have a great kind of
device here for how parents should think
about their daughters and sons the the
nice explain that yes so you can think
of your son as an exchange student from
Kazakhstan and the reason do this is to
because if you take the position of a
cultural and a temporary cultural
anthropologist then you think let me
find out the ways of these people and
what they're interested in and these
video games this is fascinating that my
son likes to watch people play video
games instead of being outside hanging
out with his friends and it's
fascinating and temporary because she's
leaving you think of your daughter as a
visiting niece from a distant state and
she is the daughter of your sister that
you are not crazy about so again this
gives you some distance and perspective
instead of this child is me the entire
batch of my worth everybody is judging
me based on this teenage behavior and
that gives them tremendous leverage
over your self-esteem you get desperate
and panic and then your voice rises
mm-hmm and your pitch gets higher and
you jab your finger yeah that was the
only that's my mom
exactly right they're very loud and
shouty there was no emotion about
parents who say that they shouldn't
treat their kids differently because of
gender so for example if you we were
talking about the four-year-old girl and
how articulate she is and the
fifteen-year-old girl and how much she
pressures you to let her do whatever she
wants the four-year-old boy often can
barely speak yet the fifteen-year-old
boy in his room with his door closed for
a good reason
what is that reason dr. mogul well just
use your imagination no I was a big boy
and so and then the mother's heartbroken
because that boy was the best boyfriend
she ever had in her whole life he looked
like if this is a biological family he
looked like her husband did when he had
a full head of hair and didn't have a
paunch yet and he followed Mom around
and said can I live right next door to
you when I grow up and you're the best
mommy in the whole wide world and then
he stops talking and then parents
paranoia kicks in because they think
what is he doing in there and what is
his future going to be like dr. mogul
say your child's behavior does not make
you a bad parent and I'm imitating you
right now what do you mean that because
I would take if my child had done
something I would certainly blame myself
for something I didn't do or I did too
much and you said listen parents should
relax because all teenage behavior is
temporary and it's unpredictable and
that's just how it is and we sort of
want them to go from being little buddy
to junior
dates men yes and a completely skip
adolescence entirely but then we send
them off to college where there's no
supervision at all so we want them to
make cheap mistakes while they're young
I am so glad my children are potty
trained and employed so I can just me
ask this book on to other people thank
you however I'm clinging to it thank you
the name of the book is voice lessons
for parents is on sale wherever you'd
like to buy your books we'll be right
back